[MUSIC PLAYING]
ANDY WADDELL: Hello, everybody.
Thank you for coming.
My name is Andy Waddell, and
I'm a technical program manager
here in Google Cloud, and
it is my great pleasure
to introduce you
today to a new service
offering from our partner IBM.
The name of the offer is IBM
Power Systems for Google Cloud,
and it's a new infrastructure
as a service offering
that you'll be
hearing about today.
Before I introduce you
to my IBM colleagues, who
are going to run most
of the presentation,
including showing
you a real live demo,
I want to emphasize a
little bit about what
it means to be an integrated
service with Google Cloud.
So the name of the offer,
again, is IBM Power Systems
for Google Cloud.
So what does the for
Google Cloud part mean?
And what we hear
time and time again,
and what we've learned
throughout doing trials
of this, is that our end
customers want to consume
a third-party service, but very
much in the same way they are
used to consuming a
first-party Google service--
so Google Compute Engine,
Google Cloud Storage--
and that can mean
a lot of things.
But for the initial integration
effort on this offer,
we've focused on four areas.
I just want to
highlight those areas,
and then we're going to
have lots of demo time.
The first is billing.
And we've integrated
the billing such
that you would purchase
the software from IBM
through the Google
Cloud Marketplace.
The billing is done
through Google,
and it will show up on your
cloud bill as a line item
along with all the Google
services you consume.
It's going to be offered on a
monthly subscription basis--
we'll get into that-- based on
the amount of infrastructure
you wish to subscribe to.
The second is the
user experience.
And this means that
when you're interacting
with IBM infrastructure,
it should be just
like you're interacting with
Google infrastructure-- that's
the web UI, the command
line tools, the API.
And I'm really excited that
what you're going to see
is a brand new set
of capabilities
that the IBM power
systems software team
has developed to make this a
good match for Google Cloud.
I'll leave most of
that for the demo.
The third area is networking.
And we spent a lot of time
carefully architecting
the network architecture
between the IBM resources
and the Google Cloud resources,
to ensure a very low latency
connection--
one that is highly available
and fault tolerant,
can also scale up as demand
grows, and most importantly
is very secure.
So we'll touch on this
a little bit later,
but when you connect to the
infrastructure from IBM,
you're never going
over the internet--
it's all done in
private IP space
that you get to
define as a customer.
And the last one
is not as technical
but it's equally important,
which is customer support.
So we're expecting you'll put
some very critical workloads
on this infrastructure, and
we want to support that.
So Google has stepped
up and is going
to do the tier 1
support for this offer.
And so what that means is if
you have an incident you'll
contact Google support at
whatever tier you are already
with Google.
We'll take command
of that incident
and if we need to
escalate to IBM for we'll
do that transparently and
resolve the issue for you.
And so with that
introduction, I'd
like to introduce a
colleague at IBM--
Carl Burnett.
Carl's a distinguished engineer
in the IBM power system
software group, and
he's going to lead you
through a small deck, and
then we'll have demo time,
and question and
answer at the end.
Thank you.
CARL BURNETT: Thank you, Andy.
So good afternoon, everyone.
Before I get started, I
want to do one more intro.
Kyle Johnson is a colleague
of mine from IBM-- one
of our senior
developers, and he's
going to take you through a
live demonstration of what
we've been working on
later in the presentation.
So hybrid multi-cloud
is a very important part
of IBM's overall strategy.
And it's really about
bringing our IBM solutions
to the customer, wherever they
are on their cloud journey--
whether it's on-prem or off-prem
in different off-prem IT
models.
And there are industry
studies that reveal that most
enterprises will continue to
run some portion of their IT
and their solutions in
their own data centers,
but at the same time, most
of those customers are
on a journey to run some
of their IT infrastructure
off-prem--
in hosted environments,
public cloud environments,
business partner
managed-solution environments.
And of those clients
that are exploring
these different
options, on average,
they're looking at least
four off-prem options
for their solutions.
So bringing power
systems onto Google Cloud
gives our customers
another great option
as they go down that
journey with on-
and off-prem IT infrastructure.
The solution we're building is
an infrastructure as a service
solution, and it's
based on our IBM Power
Systems running our PowerVM
virtualization stack.
The subscription
model is actually
a capacity for subscription
model with a monthly price,
and it is built on a concept
we called a cloud instance.
So think of a cloud instance
as a bundle of compute,
memory, storage, and network.
You then take that
cloud instance
and we give you
a user experience
so that you can
create and manage
one or more virtual
machines within that slice
of infrastructure.
So that's a cloud instance.
You might also hear me refer
to it as a t-shirt as we go
through the presentation,
because we think of them like
t-shirt sizes--
small, medium, large,
extra large, and so forth.
OK.
Now in the solution, IBM
runs the infrastructure.
So we're managing the hardware,
the systems software stack--
if you're familiar
with power systems,
those different hardware
elements like our HMC,
and so forth.
So we're taking care of that--
maintaining it, patching it--
but once the virtual machine
is deployed with a running
operating system, it's the
subscriber's responsibility
to manage and
maintain the operating
system in the stack up.
I want to just do one quick
show of hands-- how many of you
are familiar with power
systems terminology
like LPARs and HMCs?
OK, great.
So I'm talking to a crowd
who knows our vocabulary.
Very good.
The last part of this
solution involves
a low-latency interconnect,
or network, between our power
infrastructure footprint
and GCP And this gives you
a private low-latency
network between GCP
resources and power resources.
So for example, if you need
to run a database on power
on the back end, and
you want to run your app
tier on GCP compute--
they're close to
each other, they're
connected on a
low-latency network,
and you can run that
hybrid workflow.
If you need to store your
data in GCP cloud storage,
you've got a private--
you're inside the
Google network.
You can use GCP cloud storage
from your AIX instance,
for example.
While it is an IBM
solution, you'll
subscribe to it through
GCP marketplace.
So just like you subscribe to
other resources and offerings
through the
marketplace, there'll
be a tile for power systems.
You see an example
draft of that tile here.
And this is where you'll go
and see the different cloud
plans that you can purchase--
the cloud instance plans.
And here's just a
simple example of what
we might call a starter cloud
with 16 cores, 160 gig of RAM,
and 12 terabytes of
storage, and then you
can take that and partition
that up into virtual machines.
I mentioned earlier we think
of these in t-shirt sizes.
So an experience you'll be able
to have through the marketplace
is that, as your needs grow, or
as your journey here evolves,
you can change plans.
So let's say you start
with a small t-shirt,
and then you get to
a point where you
realize you need more capacity.
You can upgrade to a medium
t-shirt or a large t-shirt.
And maybe you only need to do
that for a temporary basis,
and then you can go back, let's
say, from a medium t-shirt
to a small t-shirt.
You can downgrade as well.
So the GCP marketplace
allows you to do that.
So what's under the hood?
So we're starting with
Power9 technology-- that's
our latest generation
of power, and we've
built an infrastructure
concept we call a pod.
Think of a pod as multiple
racks of equipment
that we've put together for you.
While we're starting with
our two-socket 922 systems,
our architecture
is such that we can
incorporate any of our
PowerVM M-based servers
into this environment.
So we could put a
192 core 64 terabyte
server in this
infrastructure, and it
integrates into GCP the same
way that that two-socket server
does.
It's fiber channel
connected storage.
We're leveraging 25 gig
networking down at the servers,
100 gigabit across the
racks, and then that
feeds up into an
interconnect tier to GCP.
From a systems
software perspective,
it's the same PowerVM
stack that you're probably
deploying in your own data
center, or if you're a partner,
it's what you've been building
and servicing for your clients.
My key point here is this is
the same type of infrastructure
that you deploy and use
in your own data centers.
It's fully compatible,
that's by design,
it's the same
infrastructure that we've
done all our ISV certifications
with, and so forth.
So to manage your
cloud instance,
we've built a new management
experience completely
from the ground up and it starts
with an open API compliant REST
API that we've built. We've
actually built it on GCP.
It actually runs on
Google Kubernetes engine.
It's a micro-services-based
architecture,
and that API is what sits on top
of our infrastructure footprint
and provides all the operations
for virtual machine lifecycle
management and general
service management.
So everything from
creating a new VM or LPAR,
to stopping, starting, modifying
it, ultimately deleting it
if it comes to end of
life, and we've also
put in functionality around
managing your boot images,
or your VM images--
that you can bring your VM
images from your own data
center up into the cloud, we'll
have some stock images for you,
and then also managing
your storage--
what we call your data volumes.
And Kyle is going to show
you a little bit more
detail on that later
in the presentation.
On top of that API, we've built
a couple of user interface
experiences for you.
One is a web console experience.
And you might notice it has a
similar material design to GCP
compute, and that's on purpose.
We want it to feel like a
natural extension of GCP
for you.
So it will look and feel
a lot like GCP compute,
but it will also expose
some of the unique features
of our power technology.
For example, shared cores
versus dedicated cores.
So where it makes
sense, we've actually
made those
capabilities available
for you to control as
you build and manage
your virtual machines.
We've also provided a
command line interface tool
as part of the user experience.
And one interesting
feedback that we've had-- we
did a POC last year with
several of our clients,
and we had overwhelming
feedback that an API in a CLI
was more important than
a point and click GUI.
So we've actually put more
focus on our development efforts
for the initial capability
around the command line
interface, because
that's actually
what the customers
told us they wanted.
And the command line interface
we built is called pcloud.
If you're used to
using gcloud compute,
this is going to feel
very similar to you.
It's just, again, a
natural extension,
and it gives you a command line
model for that Virtual Machine
Management.
Once you've created
these virtual machines,
you'll need to access them.
And to do that, we've built
a very innovative data plane
architecture in partnership
with Google that gives you
a mechanism so
that you can access
the virtual machines
in your cloud instance
from a GCP project.
And it's, again, a
natural extension
of your virtual private
cloud set of networks.
It's just another network that
gets integrated into your VPC
and provides a
private IP address
model to control the access
to your virtual machines.
And I'm actually
going to bring Andy
back up to take you
through a little bit
more detail of the
set of technologies
that have made this type
of integration possible.
ANDY WADDELL: Thanks, Carl.
I don't need that, thanks.
So I mentioned this
earlier, and I'll just
give you a little
bit more detail,
and we can follow later.
But at Google, we
have a lot of services
that we develop natively that
follow a similar model where
the service itself is
exposed over a range of IP
addresses that you, as the
customer, need to specify,
because you have your
own IP addressing scheme,
you may have on-prem IP
ranges, but we're always
talking about RFC 1918
private address space here.
So, for the first time ever,
we made this technology
available to a partner--
IBM in this case--
and the way it works, it's
based on an aggregation
of several Google networking
technologies that were put
together in an architecture.
So if you were to subscribe
to this offer-- let's
say you were client
1, you would first
initiate the purchase
in the marketplace,
and then you would
specify a private IP range
that you wish to use.
You would reserve that
inside your Google VPC,
in your project, and
then we would give you
a peering command,
which you would
need to run because we
can't control your project.
And what that
peering command does
is it peers you to another
VPC inside of Google,
but that's owned by IBM,
and that's the end of it.
The rest of the
plumbing, network-wise,
is handled by IBM.
Obviously you saw they have real
hardware sitting behind this.
So they handle the hybrid
network connectivity,
attaching VLANs and all that,
but that's all transparent.
All you see is some advertised
routes for the IBM LPARs,
and similarly, your routes
on your private VLAN
are advertised back.
So we think that you'll find
it very, very simple to use.
Most of the complexity is
handled by the provider--
IBM in this case, and it's going
to be very similar to if you've
ever used Google Cloud SQL.
It's a very similar
workflow, and there's
many more Google services
that are following this model.
Oh, one thing to
point out a case
is not completely obvious--
there is no connectivity
into the IBM LPAR
world from the internet without
going through Google Cloud
to begin with.
So that's important
for security,
and it gives you
all the features
that the Google front
end has in order
to secure the workloads
that you're running in IBM.
CARL BURNETT: Yeah, so thanks
for bringing that up, Andy.
So again, a key point
here is we wanted
to make sure that when
your VM is created,
it comes out secure, right.
So it's protected inside your
GCP project as a private IP,
and it's really up
to you to decide
how you're going to
make it accessible,
whether you want to open
it up to the internet
through a VPN solution or
a jumped server solution,
or maybe behind an
application server,
or maybe your intention is
to run a direct connect all
the way to your
on-prem data center,
and have connectivity all
the way from your data
center to the backing
power virtual machines.
So we wanted to give you the
ability to fully control that,
and we also wanted you
to be able to leverage
the rich diversity of
services that GCP has,
and their expertise around
networking capabilities.
And we're going to wrap up
the presentation here pretty
quickly, because we really want
to spend time showing you this,
and we also want to leave plenty
of time for your questions.
But if you want to get
with us for more details,
please contact Ming or Seenu
new here on this screen.
You've got their
email addresses,
and we can have more of a
one-on-one dialogue with you
to get more into your
needs and more and more
into the details
of our solution.
Also there's a questionnaire.
This there's a link here
to this questionnaire
that we've put together.
It's a Google form.
And please-- we'd like to
have you come and fill out
that form, tell us a little bit
about your environment, what
you see as your requirements for
a cloud-based power solution,
and that helps us understand
what we need to build,
but also helps us understand
how we can help you.
OK.
And so with that, we're
going to do a demo
to give you a much closer
look at what we've built.
And I'll turn it over to Kyle.
KYLE JOHNSON: OK.
My name's Kyle Johnson, and
I'm a senior engineer at IBM.
And I've been working on
more of the development
side for this project.
So today I'm going to give
you a walk-through of the UI
that we have created,
and then the CLI.
So all this that
we've created today
we did build a full
API for all this.
So all of our UI and our
CLI is utilizing that.
So in turn, we're
testing, as we go along,
our APIs with our UI and CLI.
So today, I want to skip
over the marketplace area.
So normally in Google, you
would go to the marketplace,
and you would subscribe to this.
And so, let's just assume
that we've already gone ahead
and we subscribed,
and so now we're
going to be brought
to our dashboard
for managing our
power resources.
So for the demo, I've
gone ahead I've already
created two partitions.
And so real quick, we're going
to go in and look at this demo
power.
And here you can see
the look and feel
is very close to what
you would see on GCP.
We tried to change the
colors a little bit
so you wouldn't
get too confused.
You might think you're
actually in GCP,
but here you're actually
managing your power resources.
So if you look, you get your
basic information-- the name,
right now we have
this in the data
center running in
us-east4, so this is not
running on my laptop.
This is not running
somewhere in my office back
in Austin, Texas.
This is actually running
in our data center.
So this has all been deployed.
You can see here we
have an active state,
this is running on an
IBM s922, we're using,
of course, IBM's
shared processor
feature and power hardware.
We gave it half a core, and
then four gigs of memory.
This one right here
is actually an AIX72,
and then down here you
manage your SSH keys
that you'd like to
deploy to the VM.
You can manage any type of
data disk you'd like to attach,
and then on this tab here,
we have this networking tab.
And so when you sign up
for this service in Google,
we're actually going to go ahead
and create this VPC peering
network--
that's part of the
sign-up process.
And so when you come in to
start creating your VMs,
you're going to have this GCP
network sitting there for you.
This is going to be the bridge
between your GCP project
and then down into
your power resources.
You are free to also create
other private networks.
So you could actually have
a private network just
for your power hardware--
maybe for some sort
of inter-communication--
but this generally
will be how you can talk to your
AIX86 to your PPC resources.
Up top here, we have
some actions you can run.
But here, I'll just
show you that you
can click on the open console,
and we're going to go ahead
and it'll immediately pull
up the AIX console to log in.
So then here's AIX, and
I can do an LPAR stat.
And you can see it has four
gigs of memory and a 0.5 CPU
entitlement.
So everything's jiving here.
OK.
Let's go ahead and actually
do what most people
would do when they log in.
Let's go ahead and create
a new power resource.
So we're going to call
this GoogleNext19-UI.
It's going to be deployed
in our us-east4 location.
We're going to go ahead
and use shared processors,
and let's give it 1 and
1/4, and six gigs of memory.
We're going to go ahead and
just use our AIX72 image that we
have out there for
us, and then we'll
go ahead and just select
our default gcpnetwork.
So I'm going to go
ahead and click create.
And you can see here--
I'm zoomed in so
our UI is crushed,
but you can see here it
just went ahead and created
this GoogleNext UI.
Some of the
information here is not
going to be available until
it all fully gets deployed,
but in a minute
we'll do a refresh,
and I can show you the
IP in its current state.
So normally for me is I use
the UI to test the features
and see what's available
to me, but when I really
want to get some real
work done, I usually
switch over and use the CLI.
So let's go ahead and
give you a nice good demo
of our pcloud CLI.
So starting off-- what?
Oh, OK.
Is that too small for everybody?
Needs a little bigger?
OK.
OK .
So as you can see we
called our command pcloud
to be really close to gcloud.
So I guess the best form
of flattery is imitation,
so most of our
commands are going
to feel very, very similar
to what you would normally
run on gcloud.
So in this root context here,
the main two available commands
that are important to you
are the compute command,
which is very similar
to a gcloud compute,
and then config, where you
would set your project.
So if I go ahead and I
click pcloud compute help,
you can see the main sessions
that we've created here for you
to manage your power hardware.
The first one is clouds--
this is where you will
switch between what we call
a cloud instance for power.
Earlier we talked
about t-shirts,
so this right here would be
the different types of cloud--
like you could buy different
t-shirts in bundles,
and this is where you
would manage those clouds.
Images is all of
our OS images, this
is where you can have
your AIX72, 71, maybe
any linux images you might have.
Instances are your actual
power VM instances.
Networks-- that's where I talked
about earlier where you could
create your private networks
and also manage your default
gcpnetwork as its h keys, or
where you can add new instance
h keys to be deployed
when you actually
provision your instance.
And then finally volumes
are all your data volumes.
So let's go ahead
and list our clouds.
And you can see here I have
one t-shirt that I purchased,
and I called it cloud9.
So we can go ahead and do
a describe on that cloud.
And you can see
that this cloud--
I created it earlier
so it's kind of small.
It has 20 processors
and 60 gigs of memory.
So now I can go back and
type in my config set cloud--
and this is going
to set up my pcloud
to just be managing
that one cloud resource.
OK, so now we can
go into compute,
and let's look at some
instances that we have.
So you can see here I do have
that the two that I showed you
earlier, and then even now
our new UI one has shown up.
So we can also dive
in a little deeper,
and we can go look
at this demo power.
And you can see here, we get a
lot more detailed information.
We have 0.5 processors
again for use of memory,
showing the IBM system
type, your IP address, you
MAC address or network,
and we give you
some IDs-- so different
volumes that might be attached,
or the OS image that's
currently installed.
Look at SSH Keys--
I do have one here that
I've created before.
We can also dive in a little
deeper to the SSH key.
And you can see here that I also
do support multiple formats.
So like gcloud, you can
specify JSON, CSV, table, YAML
and it's going to
return in that format.
If you're familiar
with gcloud, you'll
notice that every command
has a default formatting,
and we follow that same suit.
So most lists are going
to be in a table format,
and then most escribes are
going to come back in YAML,
but you're always
allowed to override
that with the format command.
Moving on we can look at images.
So images here we have an AIX72.
So that's been installed into
your cloud instance storage.
We do have a way
here that IBM is
going to keep a collection,
like a catalog of images,
for you to use that
are stock images.
So if you do the
available command,
you'll be able to list all the
stock images available for you
to copy into your cloud.
Next we'll look at networks.
So you can see here there's
that default gcpnetwork
that I spoke of earlier--
let's go ahead and do a
describe on that network.
So you can see here I
can get the information
about my CIDR, my
IP ranges that will
be assigned to my partitions
when they're created,
I have my gateway--
you can also assign
any type of DNS
that you would like
for your instances.
So you might actually
have a cloud DNS that's
running inside GCP that
you can do the routing for,
or you can even maybe deploy
your own buying server down
in your cloud instance
OK, we'll look at volumes.
So right now I
have a test volume
that was sitting out there.
Let's go ahead try
to create a volume.
So you can see here
we have many options,
but the two that we
really care about today
are going to be size
and the type of volume
you want to create.
So we are going to support
right out of the box.
We're going to have standard
disks and a flash disk,
so you'll be able to
create either one when
creating your data volumes.
So you can see here we
can type in GN19-Disk,
we'll give it a size of 20,
and we'll go ahead and use
a standard disk for now.
So now our volume
has been created.
So let's go ahead and
actually create an instance
on the command line.
So here's the help for that.
The main thing to
take away-- it's
very similar from
earlier on the UI.
We're going to supply an image,
we're going to supply some
memory, networks, the
processing you want to use,
the processor type, which
could be shared or dedicated--
so today we're going to
actually use shared--
and then we can also supply how
much memory you want to use.
And we're going to
go ahead and we're
going to attach that
volume that we just
created earlier as a data
volume to this partition.
So I go and hit enter.
So you can see here our
instance was created.
And so I think a message
to take away here
is when we create
these instances,
it's being deployed
into a cloud, so
not everything's instantaneous.
So right now a lot
of stuff is going
to be getting provision
in the back end,
but we can go ahead
and do a list.
And you can see here, we
now have a Google19-CLI
that we've just created.
And let's dive in
a little deeper.
We can do a describe.
And you can see
right now of course
we specified 0.5 processing,
we had four gigs of memory,
and the big thing important
here now is the statuses
and the build status.
So right now, we're still
provisioning this instance.
So the build status
will change to OK when
it's ready to start doing
some more operations,
but some of that information
like the networking--
that's going to show up
later once it's actually
been resolved.
OK.
But we can go ahead
and pull up a console.
So just like the UI, you can
run the command for console
on this instance, and
what it's going to do
is it's going to return
you a one-time URL.
And so when you
click on that link,
you're going to be
brought to the prompt
here as it's installing AIX.
So you can see here, from
the CLI, we've gone ahead
and we've created an
instance, and then
now we're actually
logging in to the console.
So we'll give it a few
seconds and then see
if we can get the
prompt to come up.
I guess you want me to
to DL par now, yeah, OK.
OK.
Actually now I
think I'll switch,
and let's do some
more-- oh here we go.
I'll let that run
the background.
OK, let's go ahead and do
something more interesting
that's kind of more
available on power.
So as you you may
know, we can actually
change resources while the
operating system is running.
So on power, we're going
to do what we call--
usually internally we call
it a DL par operation,
or dynamic partitioning.
So let's go ahead do a list.
Let's use the DemoPower one--
so we'll do a describe
on demo power.
And you can see here
it has 0.5 processors
and 4 gigs of memory.
So let's go ahead and
pull up a console.
We're going to log in.
I'll do an LPAR stat
here to show you
that we have four
gigs of memory.
Sorry it's hard to
see the prompt here--
4 gigs of memory
and 0.5 processors.
I'm going to go ahead
and do a VM stat one--
so this is just going
to be a simulate just
like a job running
on this system,
so we know that it
was actually live.
Let's go back to my prompt
here, and let's go ahead
and perform an update
while it's running.
So let's look at the update
command for instance.
Right here I think
were really important,
we want to just change
the processors and memory.
You can also change the
name, but that really
wouldn't be a DL par.
So let's go ahead and
do processors to 0.75,
and we'll give it six
gigs of memory instead.
So we're going to go up 0.25
on the processor and two gigs
on the memory.
Let's go ahead and hit enter.
So that's been updated.
And now we can go back
to our prompt here,
and while this is
being initiated,
you're probably going to see a
little message from AIX telling
you that the processor memory
has been changed-- right there.
It showed up really
quick, but it's
telling you that we
have six gigs of memory
and 0.75 processors.
So let me go ahead
and stop this prompt.
I can do an LPAR stat here.
And you can see
that while it was
running we've just increased
to six gigs of memory and 0.75
processors.
And we can go back to the--
sorry I keep looking
at the wrong thing--
to the command line, and
we can do a describe,
and you'll see
that it's also been
updated on the command line.
So now we're matching
what it shows--
0.75 and six gigs of memory.
I think also I can show
you-- so I'm actually
running this pcloud
inside of GCP,
so I've created an ubuntu
instance in my GCP project,
so I could technically go
ahead and I can actually
ping this network all the
way from GCP down into power.
So this is the
full link running.
So I'm actually running
pcloud on some random VM
that I have in
GCP, but I can also
talk to the network
down in the power kolo.
So that's the part they talked
about earlier with the VPC
pairing.
So it's pretty interesting.
All of it works.
We have a fully
fledged CLI and UI.
So-- oh, yeah, so
the latency-- you
can see it's a one
second millisecond,
so it's very, very fast.
Yeah, so real quick, let's see--
Just to go back, I
want to show you--
we created this UI earlier.
I don't want you
to call me a liar,
so I want to show you that our
AIX actually did boot up here.
So there you go.
[MUSIC PLAYING]